hey everyone its microphone order flows
and this is re recording of the order
flows trainer weekly group training this
was from this past week the Monday
August 13th session of 2018 this is
officially the second session now I'm
recording this because I will post it up
on YouTube
the reason it is is because I realize
now I can't rerecord these and throw
them up into the members area so you
know this video is really meant for
users of my software or you know people
that are interested in order flow it's
not meant to be just a general education
it's specific to my software and for
users specifically users of my software
but before I jump in just a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures training
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor and investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
training and knowing those was
sufficient risk capital should consider
training past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
alright so you know when I started the
presentation last week I was one of the
things that I wanted to point out to
people is if you're not on the latest
version of ninja trader and which
version is should you be on you should
be on ninjatrader eight point zero point
fifteen point one so basically version
15 and how do you find what version you
are on just give me a second here and
I'll pull it up for you let me just get
my ninja trader screen up here okay this
is the bonds bear with me here okay so
you know in the tree when you load up a
ninja trader when you start it you have
this thing is called the ninja trader
control panel go to help help go to
about and you'll see it here version 8.0
point one 5.1 64-bit this is the version
eight most recent version and and how do
you find that out is you go to google ok
once you find that out how do you
upgrade
rather you go to Google it's really
simple type in NinjaTrader 8 download
click on this thing it's NinjaTrader
comm slash platform direct enter your
license key I think mine just comes up
in here automatically hit submit and
it'll process it and it'll tell you know
once you get past it because it wants to
make sure you have a ninja trader
license key and you just choose which
version you're on 8 7 or 8 if you're
still on 7 I know people are still using
7 and that's fine you can still use 7
with the the ninja trader 7 versions of
my software but you should really
consider being on ninjatrader 8 and I
know there's a lot of people that
haven't yet you know they're ready on
ninjatrader 8 but they're not keeping up
with the the upgrades or the updates
that ninja trader puts out um you know I
know people that are on ninjatrader
version 5 an interest rate of 8 version
you know me before I jump to ninja
trader version 8 inch or 8 version 15 I
was on version 12 from earlier this year
so you know make sure you're on
ninjatrader 8 version 15 you know that's
that's the version that we're using with
the software and I mean it'll still work
on the earlier versions but you know all
the new developments that we're doing
with the software are really optimized
for a ninja trader 8 version 15 and our
new licensing thing that we're releasing
now is is works with ninja trader 8
version 15 so what was one of the what
was this past Monday's conversation
about it was the main conversation
revolved around questions about what
chart types do I use you know I do I use
range charts that use mini face charts
or I use wrinkle charts etc and I use
mainly range based charts and mini face
charts and I'll get into that in a
minute but there's two types of you know
- basically - durations on range charts
that I use I use 4 range and I use 8
range and one of the reasons why there's
a for range and there's an 8 range is
because you know on markets that are as
volatile art markets that I don't move
around so much I use a 4 range chart
markets that have
more volatility I use an 8 range chart
so things like equities I use an 8 range
chart markets like bonds I use a forming
sharts of bonds bonds 5 years 10 years I
use a 4 range chart on markets like
ESPYs mini Dow Nasdaq crude oil euro
currencies I use 8 range charts now your
Nasdaq is a bit more volatile than you
know some of these other contracts I
will I do break it out actually to a 10
range chart and why do I keep a 4 range
and an 8 range chart or emini z' is
because you know in the past before
before Trump got elected yeah just a
very boring days you'd have days where
it's a 10 range session you know the
entire session and if you're trading a 8
range or a 10 range chart and you may
need recipes you're not gonna get very
many trading opportunities that's why I
look also at a minis on a 4 range chart
but you know crude oil mini Dow your
currency 8 range chart all the way I
don't really like to look at him on you
know I had one guy looking at a three
range chart on crude oil and you know
kept telling you know he's saying he's
struggling reading the order flow well
of course you are you know the market is
moving too fast for you and you know you
had to choose a you know a chart type
that you can manage and do I look at
minute pace charts yes I do actually I I
keep usually like a 1 minute
sometimes a 5 minute chart as today as
earlier I was looking at 5 minutes and
in the SPS here so this is a 5 minute
but usually I keep it on a on a 1-minute
chart and I'm not necessarily a big fan
of minute based charts in the sense that
you know I like to see how price moves
over you know how charts are formed as
price moves rather than how charts are
made as time moves you know like here
you have well it's just a 5 minute chart
so ok it's called 40 hours to start a
new bar ok it's 12:45 I got to start a
new bar I'm much more interested in
seeing how price moves you know up or
down as you
start forming you know new VARs I mean
when you look at a range based chart you
know a new bars gonna be formed when you
cover a certain price range you know on
a forming start it's gonna be five
prices on a eight range chart it's gonna
be nine price levels because you have to
break out of that that extra level to
form a new bar so I find it much more
I'll say cleaner I don't what the term
is but I find it more effective in
reading you know range based charts then
necessarily then reading minute based
charts now again you know don't get me
wrong it doesn't mean that you have to
throw out your minute page charts you
know again I also look at minute page
charts and oddly enough you know for
what it's worth I do find that
imbalances to actually tend to work
slightly better I think in a minis on
minute base charts than on range base
charts now again that there's nothing
scientific behind that you know that's
just been my own observation you know
again don't don't say well mike says it
is that this is what he says so it's got
to be true no of course not you know do
your own research I said in my own
analysis I said you know I said mostly I
look at range based charts and you know
I think a higher percentage of stacked
imbalances don't work on range based
charts relative to minute based charts
and again you know one of the
differences when you're looking at say a
minute based chart as opposed to a range
based chart you're gonna get these times
of the day where the market is just
quiet right you're in this period where
there's not a lot going on and you're
just training basically the bid and the
offer bid an offer and you know if
you're trying to read order flow and
there's no flow coming into the market
you know you're gonna fall here and get
tired you get bored and you're gonna
stop watching the market and then the
markets gonna start to move and you're
going to miss out on it
you know boring is the trading is boring
and you know that I'm sure that's not
what a lot of people like to hear you
know they think that trading is exciting
but honestly it's it's a very boring
thing to sit through when the markets
not moving it's literally just you know
like like here's your scene it's just
basically trading the bid and the offer
the bid in the
for the bid in the offer you know for
how many minutes and you know that's why
I prefer arranged base charts is because
I don't fall into this lull or you know
this hypnotized by the market and then
that that's not moving
you know if I'm looking at a range base
chart you know going back cuz or is it
here you know okay yeah you're just
forming the little bars little bars I
could see some support is being formed
in here how to market that should
trading sideways you know we're not we
haven't come up and hit these other
levels up here you know support that
have failed has become obviously your
resistance but I know I got resistance
here so I'm sorry support here so I got
support here and resistance here and
we're just training back and forth okay
I could see that a lot clearer than if
I'm looking on a you know on a minute
base chart you know there's just not
really much going on and hard to make
heads or tails of it so that's why I
prefer you know a range based chart like
this is a mini Dallas as an eight range
chart as opposed to you know a minute
face chart you know this is my bun
charts a for range chart and you know
whether it's an eight range chart or
whether it's a four main chart I'm
looking at the exact same things okay
I'm looking for areas of price support
price rejection trap traders you know
divergence everything that I'd look on a
forming shard I'm also looking on an
eight range chart and basically it comes
down to what we all call the basic
volatility of the market you know
markets that aren't as volatile I use a
four main chart markets that then have
wider ranges more volatility I use an
eight range chart okay so that answers
that question
now another question that I get is how
many trade setups do I got you know it's
like do I have a a lot or a few and you
know I have like a handful that I call
you know my bread and butter trades and
for anyone that's been watching my
videos or have my software and I've been
listening to me for a while you know for
years rather I mean they're DARP and you
know some that have been following me
for four years and they know that I
talked about this trade the ratio this
blue number and the divergence you know
this is one of my
bread-and-butter trains that I look for
a daily basis in every market what is
the divergence well it's the numerical
law with positive Delta or a new equal
high with negative Delta and price
action confirming price action you know
it's not just a new eccolo and positive
Delta nor new go high and negative Delta
I need price action also confirm it now
there's some people out there that have
a delta divergence indicator and it just
reads the Delta and the new hire a new
low but you know if I'm going to put in
a new hire a new low I want to make sure
that price action is confirming it
because if you're making a new low
positive Delta okay well you can still
make new lows with positive Delta
because what would be happening is you
know there's there's bids in there
supporting the market that sellers are
aggressively selling it and oftentimes
you see if you have some bids in there
there's you know people see it you know
people out trade a dome or I'd say the
markets coming down hits this low at one
sixty three twenty two and there's a
thousand lots on the bid all these
little dome guys arena oh my gosh
there's a thousand Lots on the bid they
start lifting the offer so you're gonna
see positive deltas you know because
they're coming in they're thinking
they're jumping in front running that
thousand Lots on the bid that's just
there is paper supporting the market so
you do get positive deltas and the
market just keeps going lower lower
lower because you still have aggressive
sellers in there and they sort of
tricked out the guys that are trying to
read the dome and jump in front of a
paper order but anyway so my divergence
indicator reads the price action as well
in addition to the Delta okay so you
know but the point is if you have a
trading method right it has to you have
to have more than one okay because if
you have one generally it works good in
one type of market okay it's gonna work
good in a trending market or may work
good in a consolidating market but if
it's a consistent or screwed in a
trending market it's gonna work most
often miserably in a consolidating
market or if you have a method that's
great for trading in a range when the
market is trending you're gonna get
screwed big-time right you're gonna keep
taking loss loss loss loss loss and
constantly lose money so you know that's
why I say you know you got to have more
than one trade UPS I want trade setup
that you're looking for now you know
just really quick another one if I can
find it here really quick or was it I
just saw this is the buns is you know
the divergence and a prominent point of
control you know for me these are great
selling opportunities this one did it
sell off yeah a little bit here I think
it was a much better one clearer III
don't you think I'm cherry-picking but
you know there's one here you got a nice
little cell up here another one this one
failed here's a ratio and divergence
right up here this is over here is just
a divergence with no ratio so you know
these are some of the setups that I have
these are defined market reversals now I
have setups that I like to look for as
the market is trending as well so you
know when the market is trending I like
to have setups that confirm you know if
I got short up here right as this market
starts coming down I like to see
confirmation in the order flow if I'm
not hurt if I'm already short I'm not
short there's certain setups in the
order flow that I'm still looking for
okay so as the market starts moving you
know when you form a high or you form a
low and you start reversing and you know
everyone says the trend is your friends
right so now you got to have a method
for taking advantage of that trend once
it's underway rather than just try and
fade it's a whole guy got to try and buy
it here okay like if I was here's a
market that's trending higher you got a
divergence by itself you got a
divergence by itself starting on
divergence and trying to control this
one failed right but what happened is
what's assigned to me that's going to
fail is you have a bullish ratio right
here okay so you know I would take this
short this is a short I would take every
day and time I see it but I know that
I'm probably going to get I should get
out of this trade because it's a high
probability I don't get stopped out when
it follows up with a bullish ratio if I
have a bearish trade setup here when the
order flow is telling me hey you know we
got some signs of price rejection in the
sense that it's not a low but rather you
know the market is moving higher you're
making new highs sellers aren't really
interested in
selling it off you know I mean the
supply is there but how did describe
trying to think of the way to describe
it it was it's not coming out my mouth
properly but what's happening is you
know the the selling is weak is the
point I'm trying to make you know I see
in here the signs of price rejection and
it's weaker in the sense of relative to
the buying that's going on here so I
know that there's more to this move
higher and again you know when I see
failed divergences sort of group
together I also know that we're sort of
in a trend you know the market is gonna
start to trend so again you know you got
a failed divergence here failed
divergence and I failed divergence with
primary point control okay then I see
something in the order flow here is the
bullish sign as the market starts
rolling back up and of course you know
we got still positive deltas up here now
this one this high up here was
interesting because you know again it's
divergence and a ratio but if you're
watching the Delta and you can see in
here how the deltas changing is very
strong coming up to this high you hit
the high and it's very small it's
negative and maybe you're not convinced
you know maybe I you know what Mikey
you're an idiot you don't know
understand order flow I think we're
still going higher well if you read the
order flow here you okay to read the
Delta rather you see it's - 700 okay
Mikey don't what you're talking about
you got your head up your ass well by
this time you got a bearish ratio
indicating you know there's less buying
going on up in here
you know people that take it back how's
the marketing Google hires you need
buying to come in but you got a bearish
ratio which indicates that buying is
drying up already and here negative
Delta and what happens is the market
boom boom boom started selling off that
you get down in here where you got a
prominent point of control an area of
support and the market starts the bounce
here and start working its way back up
again but you know this was a great set
up on a couple different things on Delta
on your ratio on your divergence you
know this is what I talk about you know
not trying to pick highs or lows but
rather let the market tell you what's
going on you know this trade here would
have been a loss you know this is a
trade that again I as follows I say you
got to take these trades but this one
was a losing trade okay fine then you
wait for the next trade okay and then
here so
if you just had a method right if your
method it was just so I'm just gonna
trade divergences by itself okay well
let's say you got a divergence and a
ratio here this one worked here's the
divergence by itself this one failed I'm
not gonna say work and like I say yeah
you were sold right up here and covered
it down here now that's a fail this
one's a fail this one worked out but you
know when you can refine it a bit with
you know ratios and divergence or
divergence and prime opponent controls
you know you sort of eliminate trade
like this one you know if you can
eliminate imagine if in your training
you can eliminate you know 10% of your
losing trades what would that mean to
you and your bottom line at the end of
the year all right it could be a huge
difference now you know a lot of people
think that well when they learn order
flow they got a disregard everything
they've ever learned about trading no
you know what I'm saying is take the
pieces of order fill what you can add to
existing form of trading I've worked
with a lot of traders that are already
successful in their trading but they
come to me they say hey Mike you know I
want to know if I can add order flow to
my trading can it help me sort of turn
that corner or eliminate borderline
trades you know we all take those trades
that you know look good on paper you
know like textbook examples any soon as
you take it it fails on you and you know
people say I need to refine you know
some of my my entries or my exits or you
know if I could just get an extra couple
ticks out of each trade or you know you
imagine just get one tick out of each
trade so you take you know two trades a
day but you're able to get one extra
ticket of it you know what would that
mean to you at the end of the year and
you know so I get traders that already
have their method of finding support and
resistance levels you know they use
pivot levels or they got their own
method I won't get into that's not
important is what they want to know you
know curious you know how does price
react when you get to those levels are
there signs of price rejection or price
support or absorption and that's where
understanding order flow is going to
come in and you know and and help you
out as a trader you know if people have
a you know a method of saying you know
hey we get this pullback a certain
amount
but if I see there's a sign in here with
you know if the ratio of price rejection
or price support you know that's gonna
help them and you know a lot of people
have taken my tools and added it on to
their method of trading and found it
it's improve their trading you know but
again it's not will it work for
everybody maybe maybe not it depends on
on how you're training no you know I've
got a couple of indicators I got like
the price rejecter I've got the Delta
scalper and people always ask you know
what's the difference you know do I need
them both well I say how are you trading
you know I mean I don't say you got to
add every single tool that I create and
use every single tool at all times
you know I price rejector reads the
order flow looking for signs of price
rejection Delta scalper reads the order
flow and analyzes the Delta in there so
like here this is the mini Dow this is
Delta scalper so here you got a delta
scalper sell it reads reading the Delta
and price action here's you got a delta
scalper buy this one just sort of one
side wasn't got another Delta scalper
sell here and you know it's sold off a
little bit retraced back up and sold off
but it's different than say - like the
price rejector which is looking for
signs of price rejection in the order
flow you know here you know price
rejection you know we sell up in an area
where prices are being rejected to an
area a lower level where prices are
being rejected on the order flow here
and rally back up to another area of
price rejection up in here and when we
sell off again now so it it reads
different things in the order flow we're
like and one concentrates on Delta the
other one concentrates on the order flow
I mean there's no one right way to
approach the market if there was
everyone would do it and the markets
wouldn't move and that's what makes the
markets so dynamic cuz everyone's got a
different way a different viewpoint of
the market you know some people like to
look at moving averages some like
they'll look at MACD and everything and
then you know at the end of the day you
know I say well it doesn't work you know
or they'll say markets are random you
know our markets random I don't think so
I'm not a big believer in that if um
you know I mean people trade the market
so there's there's a human element
involved in the market that makes it
non-random you know you know sometimes
you'll see a lot of stuff there it just
doesn't make sense
where oh my gosh I saw these numbers I
can't make heads or tails of it you know
think it's random but if you can break
it down and look for certain things you
can see ok well I got signs of price
rejection that's why the market often
turns at these levels and again it's not
something that I I don't think the
markets are random I've never been a big
believer in the random walk theory you
know I mean the the people that come up
with these ideas most likely never
really been involved in the markets and
and don't understand the human emotion
element that goes behind it and you know
I want to expound on that any further
but I don't believe the markets are
random 100% of the time but if the
markets were random you know you
wouldn't be able to see read what people
are doing in the markets alright so you
know the other thing that I wanted to
touch on because you know I did
you know I love my users because they
they their big appetite for
understanding order flow so a lot of
them have you know everyone's software
out there and they tell me what's you
know there are those out there that
really love my software and are like my
cheerleaders and really support me and I
appreciate it I thank you guys for that
and you know so the ones that have all
the other software as well you know they
realize mine is yes I don't say
groundbreaking but you know I've come up
with a lot of ideas that have been
adapted into other user software now
again you know I I haven't I didn't
invent stacked imbalances that had been
around for a long time but you know I'm
one of the I think I'm one of the few
that have advanced order flow over the
years you know I I used to use a
different software for order flow and I
started writing my book on trading order
flow and I wanted to have I wanted to
use the charts that of the order flow
software that I was using and you know
as I talked to the owner of the software
company and he's like yeah
you can but you know you my lawyers can
guess it down with my lawyer and sign
all these papers and do all this I was
like yeah that's gonna be a headache so
I found my own programmer and created my
own order closed trader software and at
the same time I said hey you know can
you do this you know can you add ratios
can you highlight single prints can you
highlight you know the divergence with
the price action he's like yeah you can
you can do all that so you know we sat
down and he's I gave him a big list of
things that I wanted to see and one of
them was the single prints okay and if
you've been using my software since you
know 2015 you know you've been you've
been able to use these single prints and
you know there's nothing fancy about
single prints it's not some hidden thing
in the market it's just about reading
the order flow and if there's a single
print that appears in the top of a bar
or a red candle it appears there it'll
highlight it to you if it's a green bar
it'll highlight it to on the bottom and
you know that was 2015 that I released
that and just recently in the new
version of ofa the Oracle Analytics
version one point six point one what do
they got in 2018 three years later
welcome to the present single print
exhaustion at bitter ask at the highs
will be marked on the ask price and lows
be marked on the bit price how does it
look oh my gosh it's got it's the box
around the single print and you know I
got nothing against ofa I don't know
them personally or anything like that
but at least you know they have the
decency to call it what it is it's
single print exhaustion
they're not coming up and try to call it
you know some order flow single print
algo trader think you know like what
it's not you know it's a sign I've
always referred to it as price rejection
they refer to it as price exhaustion but
again I've had it in my software for
years and they just added it into their
software over the last couple weeks but
what it is is and why it's called single
print is because it's a single digit
right people are saying what is this
single print thing well it's a single
print one that's a single print and you
know you do get single prints into bars
like
cat 6 got 0 that's something else really
what it's looking at highlighted is at
the end and how do I use it is you know
I look forward in moves you know if it's
occurring at a swing high or swing low
or if it's just occurring in a middle
move it means something different to me
and I believe I've explained it already
in you know in some of the videos other
videos for my for my users and yeah
basically what it's telling me is why is
it you know why do I want to know what a
single print is and why do I call it a
single print well one it's a single
digit you know if you're a basketball
fan you remember in the 90s the Chicago
Bulls you know went 72 and 10 and
afterwards they're like well we wish we
had one more win so it'll be 73 and 9
and have that single print in the in the
record books you know the Golden State
Warriors a few years ago did a single
print for this thing this the whole
season but they lost the championship so
you know it a lot of people say well oh
that that single print doesn't matter
because he still lost a championship but
in trading it's all it is on the order
flow trader software it's a single print
at the top of the red bar a single print
at the bottom of a green bar and you
know some of these tools that I have is
to alert me to what's going on in the
market you know it's not like oh my gosh
I got a single print automatically got
get short or I got a single print a
green one got a matically get long you
can but you know that's that's not how I
use them it's more to alert me saying
hey you want you got a single print here
what it means is in this case you know I
don't look at it as price exhaustion I
look at it in terms of price rejection
you know we're starting to come off
rally back up a little bit traders are
rejecting these prices you don't have
that buying that you had earlier you
only get eight people you know eight
contracts traded here so you know when
the buying dries up well the markets not
can go higher if the buying is dried up
the binders dried up the markets going
to you know the selling is going to be
in control not the buying because
there's no more buyers and the market is
just going to naturally gravitate low
and I find it much more effective
actually at swing highs or swing lows
now in the middle of a move when we find
a good example
you know like here okay so the market is
moving it's moving I got a single print
right here how do I look at it is okay
we're moving up sellers people that are
trading against this you know against
the buying that's the aggressive buying
is going on the aggressive sellers are
weak you know I see a single print here
it's telling me that there's you know
not a lot of selling at this level that
the buying is is more in the sense that
the market is already moving it's moving
pretty quick that the counter trade is
very light here six Lots there and you
know I know guys that I've actually
taken this my the single print concept
when I've introduced it to them and I'm
not gonna get into it but they they
really built a trading plan around it
and you know they're looking for areas
of retest of those single prints you
know that yeah if you're if you're
really interested in markets that's
something you can investigate further
but as a starting point you know people
always ask you know what's a good
starting point for me in you know they
like to do their own research and build
their own trading plans say you know I
say look for single prints you know look
for a certain type of imbalance or you
know looking for divergence and/or it's
the controls there's so many different
starting points you know I know hedge
funds are adapting more and more tools
of order flow and they're actually using
the different things in order flow
they're using single prints are using
imbalances they're using divergence and
for them it's just the data point you
know they're they're analyzing all the
different factors around it so you know
who knows where order flow is gonna be
in in five years it's hopefully it
should still be effective but um you
know there's there's advancements that
are going on well beyond what you're
looking at right now and you know ssy
said you know these people have
developed an order flow chart five years
ago that haven't made any changes to it
my gosh you know and what's what's the
point of creating something and not
trying to you know make it better over
time
that's why you know when released the
new order flows 2.0 we've made slightly
more changes additions to the tools so
you know traders can get take that same
information and find an edge over other
traders that aren't using that those
tools to analyze and look at the market
so anyway guys I'll end on that note and
again you know this video is really
meant for users of my software it's you
know but it's available I posted it on
YouTube so everyone can watch it but I'm
just not able to record it and throw it
up into the members area so again you
know if your user my software you want
to join us on our weekly live training
programs you're more than welcome I send
out the invites on Monday mornings so if
you know if it's Sunday and you ever got
an invite you know so ha you know you
haven't sent me one it's because it
comes out on Monday I don't wanna send
it out too early because it'll get lost
in the emails especially over the
weekend I send them out Monday you know
before lunchtime
so again it's free for anybody that's
bought my software that wants to come in
and pay attention if you think I'm
you're not on my list just send me an
email and I'll add you to the list and
you know it's nice because you could ask
questions or you know say you made some
changes to your computer you know one of
the problems with NinjaTrader is if you
you know you upgrade windows sometimes
you do get a new machine ID okay if you
don't realize that you think I cut off
your access and a couple people so me
really nasty emails saying why did I cut
them off and really what the what the
reason was is they didn't realize that
they did a Windows upgrade and
ninjatrader kicked off a new machine ID
okay and you know they just send me
really derogatory emails which you know
whatever I think got time for those
people anyway but you be aware of that
you know be aware of changes to your
system that sometimes you know you know
that it's tied to a machine ID you can
get a new machine ID if you think
there's a problem with it let me know
but again that's why I do these weekly
calls for users of the software so that
you know at least you have a time where
you know I'm going to be you know every
week so you can you can reach out to me
and and not say well you're not replying
to my emails you know where I am so come
in and join the room so thanks everyone
have a great day and I'll see you guys
on Monday bye bye